filled with phlegm sick sick men
terrible intro everybody's sick in
GameSpot and everyone's coughing I've
lost an editor a day for the last five
days someone hasn't come in because I've
been sick I'm here ready to slay some
zombie ass
you were late yesterday yeah I was late
okay I stayed late though I know I
you're good man
listen I have you chamomile tea and I
have green tea here forgot about
probably cold now I have learned some
things from from the chat that I'd like
to talk to you about like I have learned
that if I combine my gun powders
I'd make more bullets and we've been
doing it wrong so what I'd like to do
okay yeah I didn't know this
so uh more bang for your buck that's
right so I'm gonna combine more chowder
for your powder I'm gonna combine makes
your powder much louder I didn't think
you'd be able to do it again which Tim
I'm gonna combine you've got powder it
makes you prouder stop it I'm gonna
combine these three powders I should get
more free bullets than if I did them on
their own
sweet um something I wanted to talk to
you about was should I combine this oil
additive with this machine oil is that
not something we learned adding this to
the machine oil yeah so I want to do
that yes so I'm gonna do that to
convince I will convince melted on this
game all right
so now I need the boolean what are your
map oh yeah I'm gonna make the bullet
maker and then I can do that with
shotgun too or do you think I should do
that yes you do
yeah it if it doesn't for handgun I
wanna do it
yeah they did it does as far as I know
can work how yeah I was just wondering
how much how I have I got one two three
four I got four so I could easily
combine three right now or I could
combine two and hold hold the other one
just in case so I could do that too like
what are your thoughts on like life yeah
at least combined B&B yeah this is a
nice B&B but I could mentor massages I
could do this one the proprietors are
too lovely stop it all right not into a
humorous episode are you I hope this
episode just goes off the rails
I just distract I'm afraid I'm gonna
tell you I'm afraid I'm afraid I'm going
to do all this [ __ ] and I'm gonna die
that's what I'm afraid of
okay I hope that's what happens because
letting my jokes land and they're good
jokes that won't save your jokes man all
right I meant should I combine these
sorry combine what be and what B B and B
to make super be sure I don't know it's
normally seven right
regular is just seven shotgun shells I
believe so what presumably you get like
three extra yeah so I think I should get
like six extra maybe even seven okay
let's count them
that's worth it like damn that's a great
tip thanks ja I don't remember and I'm
not aware of sorry I'm like thinking
this through and then we're gonna go out
into the wild here I just want to make
sure that we're smart do you think I
should take all these shells I don't
know probably not hey
and then yeah wait wait wait wait wait
wait what hold on a second
yeah I was yeah bring them do you're
about to go like the tram is we're going
to the tram or you need to the clock
time so shits gonna go down I think I
need this power cable right you need the
power is table to fuse wait is there's
not I don't need it
maybe I don't need a power cable there's
not another safe room near the key check
your math quick also I want to talk
about this lockpick because I keep
bringing the [ __ ] with me and I never
know I think you're gonna need it right
now no no no okay
you don't you definitely don't you don't
you know you don't need if a tram they
would not you can't come back to uptown
downtown from I remember after you the
tram
oh so it's not like they're gonna
there's gonna be a lock door on the
other side that you need to lock back
for okay but first check there's no safe
room on the way to the there's no yeah
so you got to bring everything you need
right now okay so let's talk about this
one last time
I got guns I got bullets
I got shotguns and I got shotgun bullets
I have a mixed herb that should save me
from poison but I'm already injured
I have oil power cable and a fuse I will
go through all the other items that I
have just in case gunpowder
yeah maybe you shouldn't bring the
shells that's just taking up space yeah
but if I need a man do I need the crank
I don't think you need that for the trim
if I'm being honest I think the crank
was for something like back up town up
town that it might not be worth getting
okay I'm worried about health I feel
like I should bring one more herb I just
I'm worried I'm gonna first yeah it's
bring a green herb don't waste the first
date spray [ __ ] you have a lot of health
I know I want green herb I I wanted like
ingest it now
like that's how paranoid I am what I
would wait just it's worth waiting what
are you at yellow I'm at yellow yeah
just it's there's no point and like a
muscle nemesis comes along nothing most
things aren't gonna just go from yellow
to dead okay bring you from yellow to
doesn't all right am i going out into
the world
mmm-hmm all right and I am going to my
my character's right and I'm going all
the way right and I won't go up here
I'll just go all the way okay okay here
we go this is the by far the most
stressful Resident Evil like it's very
stressful
I hate that nemesis he's always on on my
tail
he's always stressing me out it's kind
of a prick
sorry I just have anxiety okay down no
he's in the my way he's in my way he's
in my way gosh [ __ ] out of here I want
to heal he can kill me
no you got that's that's the hardest
part is dodging the first time he's
gonna be behind you from now on
oh [ __ ] what is that zombies oh I'm
staying here cuz he won't go through the
door but your shotguns gonna be wasted
from here he should pull your hand gonna
kill him not mean you go a lot of hang
around
come here stupid I'm not going over
there you hear me I'm not afraid anymore
watch home alone recently Kevin
McAllister those [ __ ]
I am the man wasn't there a video game
for it and it wasn't good there's more I
can hear them fire a shot maybe I don't
like this like what is it
so I go up took a slight right like a
tiniest right it's more of like a good
angle the only way you can't go all
right wait let me just probably ideal
that dodge right get away from the
nemesis and shoot how far can you go in
this camera shot
I don't know and once I do he's gonna
come he's gonna immediately but I'm just
gonna run Hey I'll shoot from there
quick
she had I think there was stuff in that
car I thought there was - it looked
shiny didn't it go try it quick if you
hear the music just 1:18 get out of
there you might have to kill this first
guy though might be where she might be
it could be like gunpowder a grenade or
something
yeah just kill him shotgun shotgun
shotgun don't even [ __ ] sorry I I tried
to do the 188 it didn't work it's not
working it's not working I just did it I
was practicing just shock I'm gonna go
check the car I would recommend I don't
think you I scared the [ __ ] out of go
back and check those cars I'm pretty
sure no something just happened I know
but there was in this area like I can
telling you like I was shocked on that
dude
so you buy it's time you don't waste any
time and then sorry for people's ears I
just scared the crap out of myself what
do you want me to do shotgun it and then
check the cars
[Music]
guy not quick it's a green card nice oh
that's my last slot yeah
I don't know if that was worth my home
these are the Gamble's that we take
every day that potentially if you
combine it were the right things I could
be 30 shotgun shoulder it's City Hall in
the sky you always noticed these things
stop oh my god it wasn't I'm so afraid
of that [ __ ] coming after me all right
so just just go for it
go please don't die I have like so much
anxiety is this about what happened
before
[Music]
[Music]
these pipes look
[Music]
oh my god oh my god run away I don't
know where I am
check press that switch that's a door
there's a ladder it's a switch yeah for
the ladder not gonna be that easy but
try it it's just it's a switch for the
elevator of the ladder it seems that
it's not functioning due to lack of
power isn't that convenient so those two
alcoves probably ooh they're gonna make
you go back try this one first
what alcove look at these two then these
little those little new blue probably
some sort of I'm gonna die
I should have healed you suck you know
what I never told you not you could have
healed at any point after a - yeah yeah
back in the safe room that was like five
minutes I don't believe you yeah sure
you're bad men on me oh yeah I'm gonna
blame it on you chat blamed you didn't
do that much
you don't even have to do that you don't
eat your night I wouldn't even shoot
that thing there's switch was right
there you probably could have done the
dodge damn do you know how to do the
dodge perfected dodge yet obviously not
yeah I thought I could shoot it on
yourself there I can't believe that
happened
Bunz honestly like you don't think I
should combine these if you want to
fight that thing I don't think there's
much point it looks like you can get the
switches without I'm assuming if you
escape you're not gonna have to fight it
I would just get the switches and get
out of there I don't know how to get the
switches it was it was lit I'm not
making funny oh but it was literally
right next to you I think like you were
just focused on shooting the thing well
he was there so you're saying I should
have ran the other way
is that how you feel I mean you probably
okay so assuming there's another switch
back in that first I'll go if you should
probably do the far one first and then
dodge the creature if it comes out of
that one come back to the close one and
then get out of there no no
so you're saying just dodge the creature
if he's in one alcove then you go to the
other that's what you're saying I'm
saying the switch was close enough where
you just press it really fast and then
get out of it but he was like trying to
kill me I know but hey you were focused
okay you're not listening you were
focused more on shooting it than you
weren't pressing the switch you could
press that switch and then get out of
there dodge it you really didn't even
get that far like you didn't lose the
time this is what it's not that bad I
feel like it's not exciting for everyone
else but I need to do it because I
needed these bullets
[Music]
fuse oil motor oil just a lot of
combining that's all but it is it is
worth it
wait you're missing a piece that's right
I ran out of space but now I have to
spit okay is that it
I have to go all this way again well at
least now I know a little bit better of
what's gonna happen I know the nemesis
is gonna come after me provided I can do
the same
sick sick Jukes that I did last time we
should be good I do blame you
you can't stop the blame the blame
train's a-comin
dude I'll [ __ ] your blame train up with
my with my blame train
ok ok I'm actually there you know get
hit marry dodge him Oh
there's no reason for we're on the same
team Oh what says oh the blame trains
come in yeah it'll come in I hope he
died I would love to see you're a bad
person
you just blame me for something I didn't
do I'm liking I'm standing up for myself
mark my what episode is this 6 7
okay he's dead okay where am I going
again straight and then half rights
oh right do you want me to get that
thing again yeah gun pal be any well
it's gunpowder such random it might not
be there might be something else that
packs it could be something better
potentially I don't know I actually
don't clearly know how that works in
this game why am I talking to you you
know give you the cold shoulder the rest
of this episode I'm not telling you
anything don't expect the lando
calrissian return to play all right you
should probably use the green herb if
that thing killed you in one hit it's
correct I feel strongly about it okay so
you're saying don't fight it go to the
different alcoves yeah yeah generally
maybe I can like jump over it this time
yeah sure I'll hug the wall
I'm not in a good mood just so you know
what I couldn't tell she [ __ ]
Facebook she did a belly flop onto
concrete Jill you idiot she literally
did you see how she landed I did gnarly
but oh what a butthole mouth
anyway I just I'm telling you you're
gonna have to like you're definitely
need to do some dodging but just get
ready to [ __ ] just get ready to press
that switch yeah you got me sorry I
freaked out
damn how what does that do a lot and you
need more like you
it's hard to tell when he's gonna be
there yeah you might just need to I
think you might have to do that dodge
what's the button for it remember this
no no like the r101 part dodge I think
it's our one and ellas
ah go for the switch where it's on the
left yeah
he's killing me you're standing still
and just looking at it go for the switch
please
argh leave now leave yeah that goofy
other's way
yeah he's gonna be there but just get a
quick yeah nice nice be quick about this
one okay
Oh or nice you're good you're good
you're good you got it nice but yeah now
you can press the ladders right
oh [ __ ] you still have [ __ ] alright you
know you know you want to do right you
want to lure him over here but lure him
out oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right you know I mean like so
remember how he came out farther and
farther and farther every time he does
that he like almost kills me you might
have to activate the ladder and then
come back and then okay because you're
gonna it's gonna take a while to
excavate and climb it
you could back into it nice [ __ ] no he
went back in okay you could back into it
and then just oh I see what you're
saying come get this but mm nice yeah go
for the switch first went a little too
far it's all right
I mean you're doing the right thing I
think you went too far that time dude oh
no I'm slow
I still back it up back
yeah like I'm not gonna make it just
you're going too far just like inch up
here [ __ ]
yeah I don't you don't need doesn't seem
like you need those like all those
handgun rounds and I mean had a bad day
again sooner what not understand
[Music]
disappointed with myself
I like understand the art of juking but
that [ __ ] like gets me before I can
even do anything like I got hit both
times I hit those switches you know but
you're right I don't eat shotgun shells
but don't don't you think I need them
for the tram was I not prepping for the
tram don't bring the handgun rounds okay
because that will give you into space
for at least something else to heal with
if things go wrong at least you know
what you're doing now right I have to do
all that combining again I from now when
do you think we should combine I
wouldn't even you don't think I should
combine are you upset no well yeah I'm
still pissed about the blame thing uh
you [ __ ] I did not mean to do that
wasting my god damn time
all right I feel like I can do this
really quick do you think I even need to
make the handgun rounds them
I just won't make it just don't even
worry about that yet any interest of
like just figuring this out all right
presumably there will be a safe room on
the other side of the trim like
somewhere close hopefully it's been like
I mean assuming never really helps us a
hefty journey getting past this stupid
thing all right so you don't think I
need to bring these or you don't think I
need to bring these you know what I
think you could do this is kind of
thinking ahead but when you come back to
the ladder to press the ladder switch
you could probably go into the alcove
near it so he's not coming out of the
ladder hole he's coming out of the first
switch hole and then that'll give you
more time to press the button and go oh
I see I see go into the right alcove
yeah yeah all right what do I need what
do I need a fuse sponge or something
notice damn it all right and then you
think I should bring like another heal
maybe like don't even bring the handgun
rounds bring like using shotgun this
seems right I doubt you're gonna run run
into anything that 2033 shotgun shells
isn't gonna kill so bring
just to be safe just bring em I'll bring
the hand got in case you run into says
knobby you don't want ways alright so
that's it them
well are you picking anything
yeah that should be good okay here we go
I holy [ __ ] it's hot in this room
okay well this [ __ ] game is making me
sweat I think it was the accusation what
accusation the one that you're the blame
that's not an accusation that's throw
throw and blame on me I just feel like
I'm like we're having a real hard time
ja dodging this this dude I was just
thinking there the first time I ever
played this game was in was like my
parents were finishing the basement of
my first house and like it was half done
and I remember or some I would love to
hear this but okay so that is the side
you want to go to because if you're on
the other side he follows through and
then grabs you so you want to go okay
under his armpit so I do about this guy
just use the handgun rounds I guess you
um I remember explicitly for some reason
keeping the TV and video games on the
unfinished side even though there's a
really nice like living room ish sided
to the basement and I played this on
that creepy side of the basement
it made the basement look creepy because
half of it was a normal-looking this is
a dumb story I just remember like I'd
forgot that's when I first played this
game I've only beaten this I don't even
know if I be at that time I was really
ten
are you gonna get that I am I'm just
gonna ruin I'm gonna reset them that
they won't come after me yeah you I can
practice my turn
I actually with everything that I've
learned I I still don't feel confident
about this plan vagina but it's gonna
plant it looks like a worm I don't know
where'd your green herb go I ate it [ __ ]
no I I thought went like I wish you
still had a green herb though it was
like sometimes that worm brought you to
caution sometimes it brought you down to
and just killed you be nice to go from
caution to find rather right I get it
whatever these are good things to
consider so definitely you know what
you're doing now I feel better about it
I still think he's gonna hurt me when I
make the switches though I don't
actually know how to hit those switches
without him hurting me yeah I don't know
you did it last time you did the 180
quick and got out of there I mean it's
not like surefire but you always know
how to no hate this guy this is my new
nemesis plan boy it looks kind of like
it hurt
yeah that's got like some gelgamek
all right so
yeah don't might as well get this one
right now while you're here nice
get out there yeah yeah
seems we're good clean air but do you
want to risk you think you can get this
yeah oh no way where is it he's not
there
don't worry I got it
nice okay so this is where it gets weird
try the Elco thing you know I mean okay
going to the right yeah
you ready to get out of oh you [ __ ]
it's really annoying or try this again
but make sure you like wait there as
long as possible without getting hit
wait you have to help you might as well
kill right now nice does that even
matter
where is he that do sure just like hey
you haven't it's fine you got to heal
okay so you're definitely gonna have to
use the button nothing happens
okay so here's here's what I don't I
don't think you're aligned with it
perfectly okay you've got another health
left so hear me out the alcove
definitely works so you know that alcove
is safe great so go to the alcohol and
wait it out oh [ __ ] we didn't discuss
this
oh wait is shooting it repel it okay
dude switch me
I am i you got both switches right okay
okay okay so now just maybe shoot it
with a shotgun and I'll go back into the
hole [ __ ] she'll [ __ ] I really don't
wanna do this
dammit
[Music]
run straight at the ladder he's gonna
come out for me
that's so stupid you have actually yeah
I say get out of there I don't unless
it's automatic Oh [ __ ] start tapping
what happen I'll prove to you you can
either alcove or tress shotgunning and
repelling it I don't know if that's
obscure player oh no he's coming in
there he's coming in there
[ __ ] you I dodged a lighter quick Oh God
douchebag you're just gonna have to say
[ __ ] it and I'll die
I know just go home so dead just try it
anyway oh yeah okay he's in he's in go
no I'm not
I want to wipe this goddamn episode I
don't even understand I have
accomplished nothing I think you need to
hug okay don't do that combining stuff
again please please
[Music]
you're right it's better to do that I
can't believe I've had such bad luck
with this thing no it's a dumb [ __ ]
boss it sucks like every time I learn
but I it's costing my life every time I
learn so it looked like if you hug the
wall again to the alcove then he doesn't
come out and corner you as far as I can
tell [ __ ] I don't know I just feel
broken just yeah this is not going well
No
no no no I don't want to save you
definitely got to the controls you just
have to pretty much like be really fast
I think so here's the thing I think you
were trying to press the switch which is
understandable because that makes sense
I think that you they want you to go
right through the ladder you're gonna
have to definitely do the ladders
controls get out of there and then just
sprint at it and play chicken with
bushes me no I know but you still have a
split second before he actually that's
why that dodge buttons helpful because
he's pushing you before he actually
attacks you so that if while that push
happens you could dodge it theoretically
it's just you need to like master that I
like [ __ ] hate this thing so you're
saying I have to dodge ok wait no you
don't have to I'm just saying you need
to commit to go into the ladder like
head on you do have time it's just you
need to really commit to it I'm almost
ready
I like I'm a bit broken use a green herb
now and then bring everyone yes that
I've learned
don't bring hang on
I don't even understand like what what
was calling its Richard like how many
times you have to shoot it together but
it was it wasn't even worth it cuz it
went in for like a second then came back
out
I like okay I cannot believe and I
didn't you know what I'm dumb dude
because we I didn't reload when I like
went back in I was like I'm gonna die I
like didn't reload and it was as easy as
like reloading probably could have saved
my life like I just like I think I
panicked
a little bit you know the whole thing is
like getting to me right okay yeah I've
never needed so much health and all my
[ __ ] life to be one stupid thing and
it's probably not that hard I just like
can't I can't
Juke this [ __ ] and I'm stuck in a
little corridor with him oh so [ __ ] so
funny like how low morale gets like you
die once you're just like whatever it
happens you died twice and you're like I
suck you die three times and I think I'm
gonna kill myself the day is darkest
before the dawn
shut the [ __ ] up oh that was a close one
it's probably one of the closest months
and four times that have done it what if
you get out of the that worms lair and
then you have to see the nemesis again I
will die and I will I will wipe this
episode I will wipe this goddamn episode
I will refuse I won't with the world see
how depressed I will be I marry [ __ ]
like can I get this powder later I'm
just like want to get there and deal
with this guy it was just like so upset
I'm very upset the grounds clap no no
the tram I don't think he's gonna let me
come back to Uptown I'll do it I'm just
I'm just I'm just still enough about me
I still feel oh [ __ ] I want to combine I
still feel like you could have been like
you Europe but it's not worth fighting
about okay cool
all right let's kill this but slug
Sarlacc yep and if you tell if you learn
anything new
please let me know me yeah how I learn
anything new with your brain you think
of something I'm counting on you to help
me kill this [ __ ]
I blend you I need you and you you
didn't tell me either do the thing jelly
a big dumb idiot okay get my chicken
skills get my quick turn on I want to
kill this thing so bad that it's making
me upset
[Music]
just get that switch first I would say
this one I don't know if it matters but
whatever just get whatever my nose
mapping it out
all right so as soon as I hit X quick
turn okay that's 104 it I'm just getting
the angles right Oh hear me out on this
okay
where the [ __ ] is the ladder I I have to
push the switch right puppy wasn't it
there to begin with last night the
opposite oh [ __ ] I'm not being
nice okay now just [ __ ] go forth into
the elf nice go get the letter switch
letter letter letter letter yes yes yes
you should be will get it but be ready
to just run away yeah let's not relax
yet although you do have a lot of health
uh okay I still don't
I feel like that nemesis would not be
gone yet - [ __ ] - that tram please okay
you gotta hop some boxes just so you
know pop some boxes
yeah member that's what that the dog was
on the other side last night you killed
it I believe no there might be a dog
there actually don't know if you killed
it I'm in no mood I will shoot this dog
I'll shoot that dog in the face it is
right there just pistol it he's still on
fire that thing hasn't burned don't dogs
on fire die
I mean hell hound
you're on fire admit that you've lost
take it and stride it's only a flesh
wound so the battle is over oh my god
flames and bullets won't kill this dog
I'm running out of a shock handgun
shells I am out of handgun shells you
[ __ ]
you sure got one last hit it he went
down swinging yep stop you don't even
know what those are but what are the
words can I go to know it is a really
dumb song now that I look back at it
it's always been a really I actually
liked Fall Out Boy first time it's in
the back I think quick turn no now
you're just showing off yeah this is the
highlight of my day I just lost
I just died three times ten bucks says
it doesn't get easier I just breath
sound electric I like this he's a
machine
Oh goddamnit I'm like trying to go
through it and it made me you know what
would [ __ ] suck if he didn't bring
all those or if I did it in the wrong
order and like [ __ ] hate you know out of
ya good there you go ladies Murphy but
there was nothing you could have done
yeah you're right Jill I'll operate the
cable car well why do his arms look at
skinnier right now won't be joining us
come on let's go
did he not work out for three weeks and
then come back the ladies loved him slim
but his arms were huge now what can I
use a health spray on that guy and
revive him I don't know I wouldn't waste
it see now is our village yeah whatever
care pusher it's looking good
yeah I did all the work yeah you [ __ ]
killed your friend what well we were
this is going far too well right now
well all I want to do is survive to the
next save room I do not want to do slug
man again value like pronounce you don't
want to be in this with Mema cot like
Carlos yeah way to help now he's gonna
man the Train he sucks if it's the slug
I'm gonna be mad [ __ ] that just go just
get out of here okay take one for the
team we can cut Dean
I was gonna say it doesn't care about
him that much right it's nothing stars
numbers
[Music]
if only he were actually dead he's off
the tree hi
no the brakes are out
what do you think [ __ ] bail jump yeah
number one's been working for me so far
yeah oh wait
Carlos
Oh do I kill him it's been useless
see a loser see a loser well there's a
safe room nearby that'd be sweet it
would be very important to me mentally
was my help I think you're in the clock
tower now I'm someone's bedroom imagine
being in bed and then at ramgadh all
this no no get that [ __ ] and get out of
there hurry obviously I don't even tell
you definitely don't neglect that got my
room
you know yeah you should have grown I
don't combine those right now
those two oh that's smart that's smart I
could combine these three I mean combine
two shotguns for now and then take the
other red one because you might end up
you might get beginning to point the
game where you want to start making your
neighbor got it got it
that should be good for now all right I
gotta go definitely combine the two
handgun when you get the chance
[Music]
hope there's nothing else in there well
there probably was but we'll never know
oh mama
yeah don't combine any of those right
now I think you're set on mo let's just
kind of scope this room out
that's pretty shooting room some ribbons
anywhere man I hope so I really need
them before you're good I know but you
just think you were getting in that
point you know
[Music]
you but but alright whatever no I'm so
broken
we didn't even complet whatever you
still got past that thing without losing
any help it's good if they're they go up
oh it's above the Magnum our stars' card
out you don't need any more I don't
think maybe you do who knows if there's
something to be gained from all this
it's that on my fourth goddamn attempt I
didn't even get hurt so I have a lot of
health now so that's like the only
positive I can think you have a lot of
ammo what would you like me to do my
life save and call it an episode we're
the Clocktower we were out of downtown
and uptown doesn't look like we can go
back or near the clock tower
all right we're gonna save how far do
you think I am I don't know halfway ish
maybe more
this game is hard to tell because of all
those like snafu is you run into with
nemesis
hi sweet thanks guys what one thing
people mentioned do you me to run ahead
no no we didn't do like with 1 & 2 is
like give your opinion about the game
too much what are you thinking about
three so far scariest one for sure like
the concept of the Nemesis is just
horrifying like I feel like it can never
relax I can never be comfortable um I
yeah I don't feel good I'm like always
upset I feel like I always have a sick
stomach I don't like this up I don't
like this but but is it do you think
it's a good game it's good but it's good
because of that like I would say this
might be my favorite well I like the
first one because the puzzles were the
best so in terms of remake yeah that
puzzles were really good and one and
then I think this one's like scarier so
I feel you're reacting much more this
the first one you planned out a lot more
learned a lot more this one I mean you
are for this this one seems like it's
too learned a lot from that but slow I
like this in the ideas but I feel like
it's too action-heavy for what the
controls should allow right overly
ambitious for its time yes a reasonable
reaction okay cool well sure we'll
update it at the end
goodbye after you die a lot no I blame
you you were to blame